hey what's going on hey it's cameron
with motion science um hey we're gonna
get started here with a general q a
today but i need to know
uh before i get started who
that you can see me and you can hear me
okay so
let me know if you can see me and hear
me okay
today we're going to be talking about
as i said a general q and a so there's
no specific subject
that we're talking about today it's just
an open uh q a session
where i'm here to answer your questions
and help you get some
clarity around whatever it is that you
may be uh struggling with
uh in motion design so maybe it's your
career
maybe it's something technical and in
motion design after effects
let me know and i want to help you
resolve
any issues you may be having
in motion design
um for those of you who don't
know who i am uh my name is cameron
i have been a motion designer for over
20 years and i've been working in after
effects instead of a 4d
i taught myself design and animation
i've built spec reels or built reels out
of spec work that's how i
got my career started
i was a remote freelancer for 13 years
i've owned and operated two
motion design studios
i've had the opportunity to work with
some amazing clients
studios like prolog films digital
kitchen agencies
like ogilvy and mather
and a lot of awesome awesome clients
and it looks like
um
[Music]
got a few people here
still don't know that you guys can see
me or hear me please let me know if you
can see me or hear me
uh jay gentry gentry greetings from
chicago awesome to have you here
uh
hanzla from pakistan
barry
really needs to get home so i don't miss
this
uh but yeah let me know if you can see
me and hear me i want to make sure that
you guys can hear me okay
yes we can okay thank you jay gentry i
appreciate that
it's i've had a few instances
uh over the last year actually two times
and where i'm sitting here talking and
for whatever reason
youtube was i could see the comments
coming through but i couldn't be seen or
heard so
uncle elroy i can see and hear you
awesome awesome awesome thank you
thank you for letting me know
i do want to let you know
before we get into general q a here and
if you have a question
please put it in the chat box
i want to answer as many questions as i
can today
and i'm going to stay on here and talk
to them answered
but i can't stay on here and answer
questions if there's no questions to
answer so
please let me know if you have any
questions
um
before i get to questions though i do
want to tell you that
i have a new membership that is out
it's called the career coaching
community
it is awesome registration is open this
week only
registration closes on saturday february
12th and it's called the career coaching
community
and it is a community that is set up for
you to get the
coaching you need to get your career
started to get your career
growing
uh whatever you may need in terms of
your career that's what the career
coaching community is for it's live
coaching calls with me every month it's
brand new master classes every month
about your career
and it is a private community that is
not on facebook
that is a bunch of motion designers who
are all career oriented there to
cheer you along and help you with
whatever you it is you're struggling
with your career um just open the the
doors for it on last end of last week
and i already have a bunch of new
members joining and it's really exciting
to see who's there from all over the
world
and uh
this is a community for people who are
maybe you just graduated from college
maybe you've been
dabbling in motion design for a long
time
and just haven't had a lot of luck with
it
maybe you've tried your hand at
freelancing and you're just you're
getting a client here and there but not
very many
it's great for that
it's all aspects of wherever you're at
in your career even if you're not even
starting your career but you're thinking
about starting your career that's what
this community is for it's a wide
variety of people in here
um
and it's freelancers it's full-time
employees it's people who want to start
their own studios it's all of that
that's what this coaching community is
for to help
build
you up in your career
i also want to let you know that i have
a free workshop
over at motionscience.tv workshop
and i've got a guy right outside my
window right now who's
using the blower and it's going to get
really loud here for just a second hang
on just a minute
i don't know if you guys can even hear
that but it's really distracting to me
really loud
lord
i'm curious if you guys can even hear
this or not
he's literally like five feet away from
me
and there he goes he's moving on um also
have a free workshop over motion science
dot tv slash workshop
um
let me put it up there free workshop uh
there's seven secrets to cinematic
motion design seven tips tricks and
concepts behind pro level motion design
uh plus i give you access to a very
special offer at the end that you're not
gonna find anywhere else uh so if you
haven't already checked out the workshop
definitely do i'm always promoting it
because it's awesome so i want to see
you in it
uh here we go back to me my name's
cameron and it looks like i have a few
questions that did come in
so it's pretty pretty subtle okay thank
you for uh letting me know uncle elroy i
appreciate that chainsaws yeah that's
what it sounds like a chain sauce
it's so loud
uh looks like we got a lot of people
great great people here today
thanks for being here i got a question
from uh
rivera
do motion designers need to know how to
work with photoshop and illustrator
that's an awesome question rivera
um
in general yes
in general yes
uh
there's a multitude of reasons for that
uh maybe
you're getting
designs from a designer who's passing
off photoshop files or illustrator files
to you that they need to be animated
that's a pretty common thing so you need
to know how to work within the two
programs so that you can like break
apart those layers those whatever
they're sending you whatever design
they're sending you need to understand
how to break that apart and then bring
it into an after effects and an ideal
way
to animate
so
um that that to me is key that is the
biggest thing you need to understand
about uh working with those two programs
now in terms of do you need to know how
to
you know paint in photoshop do you need
to know how to
design an illustrator
you know it kind of it depends like what
you're wanting to do right and this
falls into your career like what do you
want to do with your career do you want
to be
strictly animating then all you need to
understand is how to break apart layers
in photoshop in illustrator if you want
to know
some aspects of design then it's
somewhat important that you do
know the basic tools of photoshop in
illustrator
so that your um
here comes the blower guy again
uh so that you can work within those
programs efficiently right
it's a bonus to a studio an agency
who hires you who truly understands
motion design it's a bonus to them if
you do know how to use the programs now
i'm going to say
as a rule of thumb you need to have a
basic understanding of these programs
but do you need to be a master user of
them no
i i believe that if you can master after
effects or you're a high level user of
after effects as long as you can
understand uh the generalities of the
two programs of photoshop and
illustrator then you're perfectly okay
you know i've been using them for since
the early 2000s illustrator i still you
know i know just enough with illustrator
that i can
bring in vector logos or type or
whatever and create very basic basic
things or break basic things apart but
if i was asked to go into illustrator
and design something
no i mean i can't do i do all my design
in after effects
and in terms of photoshop
basics that i use in photoshop for my
work are
painting like
if you're cutting out someone from an
image or you need to add something into
an image or remove something whatever it
is
basics of photoshop otherwise i use
after effects
for all my other designs
uh uncle elroy
what is your view on 60 frames per
second versus 24 or 30. do you notice a
difference in smoothness do you think it
matters to the audience
um it depends on
the project you're working on so this is
all dictated by your client if you're
working for a client
they're going to tell you what frame
rate they need to have it at right or
the video editor is going to tell you
what frame it needs to be at so whatever
they say is what goes
if i'm building something for myself i'm
typically building it at 24 frames per
second
that is more cinematic if you watch
feature films
in the theater or whatever they're
almost always at 24 frames per second
and that gives you that kind of
cinematic feel that cinematic motion
also when you're working at 24 frames
per second you have less frames to
render
so if you're in after effects instead of
30 frames in a second to render you have
24 frames in cinema 4d or any 3d program
that's a huge time saver because a frame
could take a minute to render or it
could take 10 minutes to render and if
you have to render six less frames per
second
of an animation
then that's that's a game changer
60 frames per second is used a lot of
times in
well gaming uses it
there's also you know videos and things
like that that use it
i'm not a fan it creates that really
smooth motion and i just don't like it
i'm not a fan of 60 frames per second
so 60 frames is definitely more smooth
30 would be next 24
uh would be underneath that but
it really goes it depends on the look
that you're going for with your piece
and also depends on your client what
they're dictating
jay gentry what advice do you have for
cold emails i've been doing motion
design and video editing for well into
10 years now and always felt reaching
out cold was difficult
yeah great question so jay gentry were
you on the challenge that i did last
week
i don't remember because there were so
many people on it
but if you weren't in the challenge
definitely go back i put these and for
those of you who were interested i put
up five challenge videos uh replays that
i did from our challenge last week i put
those up here on youtube
and um they're up until february 12th
and there's a playlist called like
realize your motion graphic career
uh video series that's where you're
gonna find these videos there's a video
i think it's day three and i i would
advise anyone who wants a career to go
through all five videos but there's a
video number three where i talk about
cold email in more detail
but
essentially for a cold email all you
need is
two paragraphs right two short
paragraphs where you're introducing
who you are
like you know hey my name is cameron i'm
a
motion designer who specializes in
2d and two and a half d
design and animation right that's what i
would say
i've got
you know 10 years of experience
freelancing
you know maybe one more sense a little
bit about me you don't want to get cute
cutesy with it you just want to give a
little bit about you and who you are
right that's that's one paragraph the
second paragraph is
um maybe that gets more into your
experience but i have 10 years
experience
i have a recent reel i'd like to show
you
you link to that reel
with a very simple hyperlink that that
launches your website your like very
simple website like a one-page website
where you're real when you launch it
your reel is front and center so as a
creative director or an executive
producer when i click that link
i don't want i want to be taken to a
page where i can see your reel and
i don't have to search around for it if
i have to search around for it i'm
probably going to
leave that that page and
look at my next email
so it's pretty simple
uh you can also end with like you know
hey i'm available starting
february 8th
uh for freelance work
you also want to to say in there things
like you know if you're a remote-based
freelancer or if you're on site like
let's say you live in los angeles in the
u.s if i lived in l.a or new york
i would say hey i'm
located in the city
because that's to some studios that's a
big thing to others it's not
when i was starting out freelancing and
for many many years
uh i had to state that i was a remote
freelancer because i would get people
interested
in my real and they'd be like hey we
want to hire you when can you start and
you know how long does it take to get to
our office here in new york i'd be like
well i can start right away but i'm in
kansas city at this time and i do remote
based work only oh well we can't work
with you as a remote remote artist for
this job we'll keep you in mind for a
future one so it just
if you're not straight up with that
person and telling them like be i'm all
about transparency right being very
transparent
in what your abilities are what your
availability is how you like to work
but in two very short paragraphs
that will save a lot of headache uh also
creative vectors producers will
appreciate that that you're that you're
you are being transparent and
straightforward with who you are and
you're available and things like that
so um also i don't believe
like i think it was during that
challenge someone said that they were
sending out like thousands of emails a
week or something like that
i don't believe in that i feel i believe
in sending out a few emails a week
and that is because you have targeted
like for me i wanted to work for studios
right i wanted to work for post studios
uh post-production houses
and so i was very careful in selecting
who i wanted to work for right i made a
list of companies i wanted to work for
and then once i had that list i found
out who i needed to contact
and then i sent that person an email
i wasn't making just this huge random
list like you're sending your your real
out to thousands of people that tells me
that you're not having a whole lot of
career clarity around where you want to
go with your career uh so it's really
important that you you hand select those
few studios you want to go after or
agencies or or corporate companies
whoever they may be
and that you
send just a few a week and then you keep
like a little you know simple
spreadsheet or something like hey
reached out to this person they
responded reached out to this person
they didn't respond so i'll follow up in
a couple weeks
um i do believe in that following up
typically one time if they don't respond
after a second time i just i forget it
forget about them but
um
don't
i know it can be kind of intimidating to
send an email a cold email to no one who
to someone who doesn't know who you are
but just have some faith have some some
belief in yourself
and you never know where it's going to
lead and a lot of times producers share
contacts so you may apply to one company
and right now they don't have an opening
or they don't have a job that you're a
fit for but they could pass your name on
to another producer friend that they
have
at another place who may end up
contacting you so that's happened to me
a lot in my career just out of the blue
being contacted by studios saying hey we
got your name from somebody and we want
to see if you're available we saw your
work so um
if you're not j gentry i can't remember
if again if you're in the challenge or
not i have the career coaching community
open this week
um i have a master class coming out and
i think it's in two months uh that talks
about cold emails and things like that
and i give like templates out like
here's a template you can copy and paste
and put in your own information um but
i'm also on these calls to help you know
we do live q and a's within the
community where i will give you specific
feedback on your particular
circumstance
did you at some point your career work
as like an animator like 2d animation or
something i mean i started as an
animator
um
i started as a generalist
as a junior motion designer moved to a
senior motion designer
still focused mainly on animation
and then when i went freelance animation
until i was challenged to design style
frames and then realized i could
actually design
so now i'm a designer and animator i
believe that most motion designers
should be both designers and animators
it makes you more well-rounded as a
motion designer and you're going to open
up a lot more career opportunities for
yourself if you can do that
uh uncle elroy what are your views on
nuke versus after effects so i i've used
nuke
maybe twice
very in a very simple manner
nuke is amazing for compositing
node based compositing you can get some
amazing results
but i believe that
for the work i have done through my
career i can get the same results with
after effects maybe there's a few more
layers involved
but
after effects has always been my go-to
program
it continues to be my go-to program
because it is so versatile so nuke is
basically just a compositing program
whereas after for after effects can do
compositing as well as animation and
visual effects work and and additional
things like that new can do visual
effects work as well
but uh
in my opinion after effects
is uh
what's the word
just a more versatile well-rounded
program that has a whole lot more
possibilities
um
hey lauren what's going on man
uh gentry yeah definitely watch video
number three
and i would advise anyone uh who's
interested to watch all five videos in
sequence from one through five uh this
week before they disappear
hey larkin great to have you on here
um uncle elroy have you considered doing
a video where you critique or react to
submitted reels of people's work
yeah so i do that in stylecraft so um if
you're part of stylecraft you're part of
my stylecraft community and i critique
work
on what we call feedback fridays
so
lots of work people post in the
community and um
i do that once a month and i critique
your work and give you pointers and
what's cool about it is you get to see
your work critiqued as well as
um
many other artists were critiqued uh
which is very eye-opening like you
actually can learn
just as much or if not more by watching
other people's work critiqued
other than your own so you start to see
things
that maybe you weren't aware of
in your own work
because you're seeing it critiqued in
other people's work
so yeah i do that
once a month feedback fridays through
stylecraft
it's a lot of fun too
um
yeah and jade gentry nuke is more uh for
specialists and ae is more for
generalist designers i would 100 agree
with that
um
ryotech how can i go out of my country
to make career in motion animation in my
country we can't get good deals here so
i understand that so why not go
freelance remote remote freelance
you don't have to
leave your country at least i don't
think you do
there's remote based work and there are
sites all over the internet for remote
based work
that you can get again like here i am in
the us and i'm in the when i was the
majority of my career was in the middle
of the u.s in a city that was not did
not have
um
motion graphic studios there was a
couple of them but they were small
and all my work was coming from the east
and west coast of the us and
the uk and europe
places like that so i was able to work
outside of the us
by just being a remote freelancer
it just it all comes down to having your
reel
and you have to have a powerful reel and
you have to go after clients
that um
are ideal matches for your reel right so
you want to create work on your reel
that you want to show to potential
clients who will pay you to do that work
and then they will see that reel they
will hire you they will pay you
and you just keep replacing elements on
your reel with better work and your reel
gets better and better
hey eleanor what's going on
you got any questions for me today i
know you always have a lot of questions
you gotta have one for me today
abraham do you use freelancing sites
like upwork or fiverr i do not
to be honest i'm not a huge fan of
either one of those sites for motion
designers i do use sites like upwork to
hire um i've hired a writer on upwork
i've hired
a coder
on upwork
but
what i found especially on fiverr is
that motion designers are not charging
enough for
what they can do
and it's bad for the industry
and
it
minimizing minimizes the talents that we
have as motion designers so no i don't
believe in using fiverr
upwork is better than fiverr but from
what i've seen in my experience of of
looking for motion designers to help
with projects and things like that
again
they're not charging enough
and
it's just it's just to me bad for the
industry so
no there's other sites that i believe in
um
and again i talked about these on the
challenge from last week
uh glassdoor indeed motionographer
motionographer is more for like high-end
freelance design
but indeed glassdoor linkedin's a great
place to find work uh instagram is an
amazing place to find work
working not working creative circle
those are just some of them
is there a renderer in cinema 40 you
prefer to use ie redshift arnold octane
i use the standard physical renderer in
cinema 4d
my buddies
are kind of
split between redshift and octane
i've seen awesome results out of both
i have some buddies who think that
redshift is the way to go because it's
been absorbed by
maxon and it will be like the renderer
you know later on down the road
it's hard to say uh there's also like i
said arnold
uh i know some people use arnold that
really like it and uh the corona
renderer
is pretty awesome
if you haven't seen that one check it
out
um
but i think too when you're starting off
in in motion and you're starting off in
3d work just focus on the renderer
that's built into cinema 4d you have to
understand the basics of the program and
i don't know where you're at uncle elroy
maybe you have a lot of experience in
cinema 4d
but for those of you who don't if you're
just starting out
use the render that's built into cinema
4d
uh to get your you know to get an
understanding of how the program works
how to work with 3d
same goes for after effects i think that
when you're starting out that
you don't need all these third-party
plug-ins there's so much inside of after
effects it can keep you busy for years
and years and years without having to
use these third-party plug-ins so
it's best just to learn the softwares
without all these add-ons and then start
adding them in
to tack onto what abraham was asking how
do you feel about job hunts on social
platforms
i think it's great i think it's great um
i i've i don't know
like on linkedin you know like there's
some head hunters on there that look for
you know to like match you up
as a motion designer with other
companies i don't know how that i never
used it i never had success with it i
think i was approached once or twice
but this has been years ago
um and it seems like nothing ever came
from it
but um i don't know linkedin is a great
place to connect you know for business
so why not
um
indeed
you know do a quick search on there for
motion design jobs you're going to see
them zip recruit i'm not familiar with
but um
yeah i mean and again like social
platforms like instagram i know so many
motion designers who have gone through
style craft and who have posted their
work on instagram
uh
who and then i've shared their work and
things like that and they've gotten hit
up by different
um
employers like artists music artists and
and corporate
companies to hire them for jobs that
they've had a lot of success with
that's just through the dms on instagram
daniel cruz my role is a combination of
2d and 3d animation but i keep landing
social media focused jobs which are very
boring and limited rather work for like
the mill
any tips on what i'm doing wrong um
great question daniel
i'd have to see you're real
uh to know
um
i mean again it's a matter of of who's
who you're attracting with your reel
uh that you're attracting social media
focused jobs i mean i don't know if
you're putting that out there daniel
that that you're um
going after so like if you're posting
all stuff on social media like hey look
at the social media job i just did then
you're gonna keep attracting that at
some point you have to say
oh well i probably should stop posting
this because i'm attracting this work
right
like for me if i don't want to do
character animation i'm not i've done
character animation in the past i don't
ever put it on my reel or on my website
because
i don't want to attract more of that
work
so you need to look at that you need to
look at what's on your reel
and if you don't have the right work to
attract working for companies like the
mill then you need to create personal
spec work
and fill your reel with that
i'm a huge proponent of personal spec
work
um
daniel i mean it sounds like you'd be a
great
match for the career coaching community
if you're not already in there
something to check out you guys can go
to motionscience.tv
and you'll find under products you'll
find it at the bottom or you can do
motionscience.tv
backslash
career hyphen coaching hyphen community
it's not the best url it's not super
easy but um and i probably should have
made something here
with the link on it
actually i'll put it here in the
comments
um
motion science dot tv slash career
so it's spell right coaching
community
uh again the registration closes this
saturday and then it's closed until next
fall so
i want to help out as many motion
designers as i can and when you have
specific questions like this sometimes
it's better for me to take a look at
your reel
in fact if you sign up i have an offer
you get a one-time
offer of sending me your demo reel where
i analyze it i give you a video anal
handle
analysis of your reel and help you kind
of pinpoint some things that you can
adjust so something to think about
but i would definitely look at who
you're attracting
and why you're attracting them
let's see here
oh no i'm working full time but want to
find clients is there any way i can find
smaller jobs from clients until i have
more time great question
um
moonlighting right again i talked about
this on my challenge last week
moonlighting is an excellent opportunity
for you to test your feet
uh dip your toes in the water
freelancing so you can have a full-time
job doing anything you could be a
full-time motion designer or you could
be a full-time nurse right or a
full-time carpenter whatever it is
that's your full-time gig when you come
home at night and on the weekends you
can freelance and it's typically for
smaller
jobs
and
you can get a taste of what it's like to
freelance and create motion design and
get paid to do it
moonlighting
when you do moonlight it's very
important that you're very transparent
with your
client your potential client that this
is something you're doing on the side
right you want to be upfront honest with
your client and say
you know by the way i have a full-time
job it's nine to six every day but at
night and on the weekends i have plenty
of time to devote to your
job
and if that's okay with you then i'd
love to to take it on and work on it now
sometimes that works because maybe that
they have a
deadline that's not very close it's
pushed out so you have plenty of time to
work on it
it just kind of depends and maybe it's a
smaller job and that's okay
so it just depends but if you're if
you're up front you're honest and
transparent with your client then
they're going to appreciate the fact
that you you told them up front it shows
them that hey i can trust this person
because they're telling me like during
the day from nine to six they're
probably not gonna be available to chat
to talk about revisions to talk about
things that need to be changed or
whatever
but moonlighting is an awesome way to
get started
in the world of motion design and in
freelancing
um but why inform
formative channel
hi can you tell us some tips to study
motion graphics academically i would 100
recommend emotion science.tv
if you're just getting into motion
graphics i have a course a three
volume course called after effects
academy volume one two and three
that is awesome for people who either
you've never touched after effects and
you want to get started
maybe you know some basics about after
effects but you want to go further into
what it can actually do
[Music]
into all the way into volume 3 which is
getting very much into 3d layers and 3d
cameras and things like that
so i would 100 recommend
motion science there's other sites out
there other online schools
as well
but uh no one quite does it the way
motion science does
we teach a different approach or i teach
a different approach
to it's more cinematic motion design
um owner karen can we see your character
animation would be interesting to see no
you cannot no you cannot
it's actually decent stuff uh just like
a few different pieces well actually
it's a hand it's um i worked on one long
two long form videos
and then i've kind of done some
pieces in between for some other
projects where i filled in the gaps for
them
[Music]
um
but no you're not going to see it sorry
barry hi what's your go-to for title
inspiration i love art of the title it's
i believe it's art of the title dot com
um that's a great website for title
design inspiration there's just so much
there
um
i also get a lot of title inspiration
just off instagram
um
because to me title inspiration doesn't
literally have to be from a tv show or a
film
it could be
uh just like on it on instagram you see
a 5 or 10 second clip of
a title
of some sort
um
in some type of motion design scene
right and that could be inspirational
enough for me to draw inspiration to
build something of my own right so uh
there's that and then instagram
if you don't follow motion science on
instagram it's motionscience.com or it's
instagram.com motion science i believe
um
i have a lot of boards on there that a
lot of them relate back to title design
so lots of inspiration there
zach i took your advice and did some
personal spec work last week it was on
instagram some cool contrast work
amazing did you tag motion science um i
have someone who helps with the my
social media channels because i can't do
it all
um
and she does a lot of the instagram work
so i don't know if i would have seen i'm
on there a lot but sometimes i miss
things so did you tag motion science
uh because if you do we'll repost your
work
but yeah zach i mean spec work is
everything personal spec work now i'm
not talking about spec work that you do
for a client for free i don't believe in
that
but doing spec work for yourself to
build up your portfolio is an amazing
thing that's how i got started in motion
design that's how i i leaped in my
career every time it took me three demo
reels to go from earning nineteen
thousand dollars a year to earning a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year and then i went beyond that but it
only took three demo reels to do that
uh let's see danny
thanks for providing all this
information my experience up to this
point has been other artists my market
don't share ideas or anything for fear
of losing business to someone else yeah
that's a great point danny um
it is like there's a lot of artists who
are afraid to share their secrets their
trade secrets um
and like how they get the business and
how they they do technical things and
motion design
i like to share as much as i can
again you'd probably be an awesome fit
for career coaching community there's
gonna be a lot a lot of stuff shared
there in detail right that's why i make
these master classes
there's a new master class that comes
out every month
um they're typically since we're just
getting started but my goal is to aim
for 20 to 60 minutes per master class a
month so it's not like this time
consuming video that you're spending
hours and hours watching this stuff
these are to the point
master classes that get you
in to learn what you need to learn
and then out so they're gonna have a lot
of information within them but um this
is the kind of the stuff you know here
the stuff i share on youtube is more
like the generalized idea
or generalized information that can help
you tremendously and i know people who
have never
purchased anything from motion science
and have a lot of success uh it's just i
think that i believe that you can speed
up your your career path your success
path
um
by doing things like courses and
communities and things like that so
danny definitely check out the career
coaching community if you haven't
already
daniel's going to sign up with get my
feedback on the real awesome
you're welcome daniel
thanks for having the question putting
it on here i appreciate i love all your
questions that come through they're
awesome
jay gentry what's your thoughts on
adding a skill section to your resume
what to add what to not add so on
resumes um in motion design i don't
believe that they're super important
when i had two studios my second studio
i owned um the first video was just me
and another guy really small the second
studio was me and another guy and we had
six employees i believe
and we were constantly looking for
freelancers to help us as well as
full-time employees and so i would get a
lot of emails
from potentials with the reels and
things like that and
i never once really cared to look at a
resume if they attached it
excuse me if they attached the resume
sometimes i'd look at it um
because it's kind of fun to see what the
background is but i don't think that
it's super important
uh to me you're real your demo reel is
your resume right now if you decide that
you want to put a resume together
because maybe some clients do require
that like maybe more of a corporate
client more of a corporate business who
doesn't
fully understand motion design any
corporate company i've ever worked for
that had a motion design department
within it they didn't look for resumes
right now if i if i did work for a
company that was new to the world of
motion design and maybe they were trying
to do a one-off project they might look
at a resume and say well you know but i
don't even know if they're going to
understand everything
so if you're going to create a resume
um
i sure add a skill section i think
that's great
you could just you know keep it somewhat
generic you don't need to get super
detailed
because again
is a client going to fully understand
what you're saying if it's corporate
based
and then if you're sending your stuff to
a studio or an agency
a post house i don't think they're going
to care so much about your resume
uh
i don't know why i just clicked on that
one
um
can you tell your pc confederate
configuration so i'm an apple guy
and i'm on an imac right here imac um
i mean it's an older one
look it up here
uh this is a
2017 5k
retina 5k 27 inch imac it's still the
intel chip
this computer has 64 gigs of
ram
[Music]
and
it has a
4.2 gigahertz quad-core intel core i7 so
the biggest thing with after effects is
you want the fastest cpu you can get
and you want as much memory or ram as
you can get so like i have 64 gigs of
ram ddr4
uh 128 would be better
also have a macbook pro laptop with the
m1 chip so this is not the m1 pro or m1
max chip
and it's a powerhouse as well so
i will be upgrading i seem to upgrade
about every five years sometimes longer
but with after effects if you have a
really fast cpu
and you have decent amount of ram that's
all you really need
when you get into
rendering
with cinema 4d or 3d programs then
that's when the graphics card comes into
play now you want a pretty powerful
graphics card but again i don't have any
of that installed here because i don't
do a ton of that render intensive work
and i don't think that it's necessarily
needed i think a lot of times it's
overkill right
so
you don't need some crazy computer you
just need a basic computer
okay zach did tag it i hope did you i
don't know if you got reposted or not
what uh
central mo see yeah i'm curious what the
name of it was i'll just go back back
and look
is your aka alias of mr black because
you usually wear black or is it
something darker
well when i was younger
um
in my like teenage years
my high school friends
i always wore bl i love black right it's
one of my favorite colors even though
it's like well it's not a color but
um i've always worn a lot of black
um
i was always drawn to darker music like
nine inch nails
uh darker even like i listen to every
type of music really except for country
so much
but i like always the darker side of
music but i do like you know poppy stuff
too
uh but i'm more drawn to that so you can
see in my style that my stuff is moodier
darker typically
so aka
so mr black was kind of like my friends
back in the day used to hey mr block
what's going on
uh they they joke around with me about
trent resner
and the crow and those that those type
of movies and so mr black kind of stuck
with me and then when i went freelance i
was like aka mr black
so it worked
um so gentry your response to my
informative channel so i would say um
you said you look at school of motion
motion hatch for other resources to
check out
but motion sciences goat i appreciate
that
uh career coaching community is
something that i'm still trying to
explain to people because everyone
thinks of motion science is all about
design and animation
um but with career coaching community
this is what i'm trying to expand
on into more of the business world
in motion design i've had a very
successful career
and
people often ask me like how did you get
this career because i'm self-taught
right i didn't go to school for this
i had to teach myself when i started
there was no youtube i had to teach
myself out of books i had two books to
study from and a lot of it was just me
practicing and teaching myself
and i got to a very high level position
very quickly in motion design
and i was also one of the first
generations to go into motion design so
i have a lot of information about how to
have a successful career and how to
speed up your career path which is why
i've started the career coaching
community
um
other see owner are there still going to
be workshops like what do you mean owner
like
in pro flows or workshops
jc hi cameron how can i develop the
basic design i realized i need to
develop the basic design before doing
motion graphics like artwork stuff can
you recommend design foundation courses
100 style craft
100 stylecraft
i created stylecraft you can find it at
motionscience.tv i created it because i
found that motion designers know
typically no animation they know the
motion side of it but they don't know
the design side of it it's super
important even if you don't want to be a
designer you need to understand the the
the
graphic fundamentals like you're saying
jay
it's important they understand that
because if we're if we're we're given a
design and we have to animate that
design
well that design has to move in some way
and it ends up in different places on
the screen even and it's important that
you understand where those elements need
to end up because if they just end up in
random places and you don't know
understand design principles and things
like that
well your
finished composition your finished
animation is not going to look that
great
so i created stylecraft to start
teaching motion designers how to design
and how actually easy it is to design
right
when i jumped into motion design i
didn't know how to design i never took
an art class in my life no idea how to
do it but when i started teaching myself
because i was challenged by a client to
do it
my
excuse me my first design job was
actually for verizon wireless the phone
company through a studio
and he the creative director that studio
challenged me he's like i think he can
do it i think he can design and so he
gave me that confidence to try and i
tried it out for a week and i had
success with it and so i started
teaching myself
different ways of design and i studied a
lot of designers
that's a great way to learn as well jay
is just find designer motion designers
that you are inspired by
and look at their work and study their
work and
and look at it and say well what about
this piece is inspiring to me why do i
love this piece why am i drawn to this
piece what are they doing well and how
can i apply that to my own work you're
not copying this artist you're just
learning like oh look they they used
this kind of typography in this instance
or they used this type of color palette
or they used textures or they used flat
animation or flat artwork or
three-dimensional whatever it is
you need to study that but 100
stylecraft stylecraft registration is
closed but it is going to open back up
in march so i open it up just like
career coaching community i open up
registration for 10 days and then i
close it
so you either get in at that time or you
don't
but 100 percent
starcraft in the meantime start
looking at other designers other
inspiration
to see what you're drawn to
but you're on the right track
hello from brazil what's going on
uh well guys i'm gonna wrap up this um
live q a today lots of great um
questions
and all that um
well here's one more question i'm gonna
answer real
quick devin mann what do you suggest the
best tool software to begin very good
motion design and how so it doesn't
actually start like you need to
understand the software like i would
suggest after effects okay
after effects is more than just this
basic flat artwork it's it's so much
more
it's it's after effects is cinematic
right after effects is so amazing what
you can do with it so check out after
effects but beyond just learning the
software start learning the the
principles of design the elements and
principles of design look those up go to
youtube here on youtube for motion
science i have two videos elements of
design and the principles of design look
at those start studying those and start
studying other people's work to
to understand what makes up good motion
design and start practicing that's what
it comes down to you have to practice
you can read all day long you can watch
someone else do their work all day long
but you have to put into practice
uh yourself in order to um
to get better at at your craft so
that's how you do it uh daniel thank you
for signing up for the community looking
forward to getting uh getting you out of
your rut and helping you you get there
it's amazing anyone who's interested
career coaching community uh it's
registration is open right now as of
today february 8th when i recorded this
uh it closes on february 12th at
midnight pacific standard time i hope to
see a lot of a lot of you in there so i
can help you even more uh further your
career uh as always
i want to say thank you for being here
today
and really appreciate all your questions
that came in and
they're awesome
and i want to wrap with this which i
like to wrap now
the best way to get better motion
graphics is to keep creating and
practicing just like i said keep
creating and practicing watch other
people's work
learn from it and find ways that you can
improve upon it i want you to stay
motivated in your work i want you to
experiment with new techniques and above
all else have fun with your work have
fun
okay
with enough practice you're going to be
a master of your craft you're going to
produce stunning visual results yourself
and this is going to capture people's
attention
thank you so much for being here today
everyone as always
my name is cameron and this is motion
science
you